president Trump is delaying a sweeping
series of immigration rates but he's
also telling congressional Democrats in
his words to get moving the president
gave them two weeks to change us asylum
law to cut down on the number of
migrants entering the US illegally
Manuel Bojorquez is in Miami with more
on this story good morning to you Manny
so let's start with this what does the
delay mean for undocumented migrants
well good morning the short answer is
this those who were targeted as part of
this operation can still be deported now
beginning yesterday Immigration and
Customs Enforcement had planned to begin
a mass roundup of about 2,000 immigrants
including families in as many as 10
reported cities including right here in
Miami those targeted included
undocumented migrants who either missed
a court hearing or already received a
final deportation order over the weekend
acting ice director Mark Morgan made it
clear agents will continue to carry out
court-ordered deportations president
Trump's decision to delay the new raids
followed an outcry from Democrats
including House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
many leaders across the country who
opposed the president's hardline
immigration policies now despite the
delay those who are subject to
deportation are still uneasy and over
the weekend immigrant advocates
expressed their support what you're
seeing was a protest that happened in
Los Angeles but I can also tell you that
they were giving out legal advice from
watching the situation unfold here in
Miami over the weekend and in other
major cities there were Flyers that were
distributed over social media reminding
undocumented immigrants of their rights
including asking for a search warrant
should ice agents knock on their door
Tony
Manny thank you